Welcome. So we're going to continue a
today talking about a drug delivery.
And I want to pick up where
I started last time. Uh,
where at the end of the class I was trying
to convince you that one way to think
about a drug delivery was to take
what we know is a complex system,
the human body and
represented in a simple way.
And this is a common approach to uh,
to um,
engineering where you take a system that
might be a complex system and you say,
how can I represent it in the most simple
way? And then you ask the question,
what comes out of that simple description?
And does it fit experimental evidence,
right?
Does it match what we know
about how things work?
And so this simplification was to take
the human body and represented as a
simple stirred vessel of
water and to ask the question,
if we introduce drugs into the body,
do they behave in the same way as if
I introduced drugs into this wealth,
stirred, uh, well stirred
vessel full of water?
Are there things that match about it?
And so we made the vessel a little bit
more complicated than a simple tank full
of water in that we,
uh,
we allow its volume to be variable and
this is going to account for the fact
that when we introduce
drugs into the body,
some of them are going to go to
different compartments within the body.
Some will remain confined to the
blood plasma space, for example,
while some will be
distributed more widely.
So we'll adjust the volume of the vessel
to match the drug some way and how it's
distributed.
And we'll assume that it's a,
that it's a magical vessel and another
sense and that drugs disappear and they
disappear in a very orderly
fashion. That is, they,
the rate of disappearance of the drugs
is equal to some constant times the
concentration.
So it's a first order.
It's a first order rate of
elimination from this a compartment.
And if we do that, what I wrote
on the board, uh, today, uh,
the equations that are in the box at the
end of the chapter in chapter 14, uh,
just uh, to review them very quickly,
that if we have a system like this,
we know that mass has to be conserved.
And one way to write down the conservation
of mass equation is like this.
The amount that comes in minus
the amount that goes out,
plus any molecules that are generated
inside minus any molecules that are
consumed inside the system has
to be equal to accumulation.
And accumulation is just the
rate of change of concentration.
If molecules are are
accumulating inside the vessel,
that means their concentration
is either going up or down.
And so cumulation is the rate of
change with time of the total number of
molecules inside the vessel.
And if we went through this analysis for
the system that I drew up here and the
particular circumstance that I'm going
to inject drugs in to the body or into
this vessel at time,
t equals zero after time t equals zero,
no molecules are going
to be introduced right?
So this is when I'm just giving all the
drug at once at the beginning so I'm
simulating and intravenous injection so
there's nothing coming in and there's
nothing going out over the in terms of
drugs introduced over the time that I'm
interested in
your no molecules of drug
are being generated inside
the body but they are being
consumed,
they are disappearing in some way and
they're disappearing by this first order
process where the rate of disappearance
is equal to a constant times the number
of molecules that are still available
and I could solve this equation,
this differential equation
I I've told you yet,
if you don't know about solving
differential equations, don't worry.
Another way to think about
it is here's the solution.
You could convince yourself that this
solution does match this equation.
If I take the derivative of
this and plug it back in here,
do I get the right answer?
It's another way to think about it.
Or You could just trust me that it is
the right solution to the equation and we
also have to know one more thing.
How many molecules of drug we introduced
at the beginning and we're going to
call that number m zero.
And so the final result is Amazon
equal to m zero e to the minus KT.
The amount of drug that I have within
the body at any time is equal to the
amount I had at times zero times and
exponential to the minus k times t power
whereK is this rate constant.
So if I knew what the rate constant was,
I knew how long after the injection I
knew how many molecules I'd injected at
the beginning, I could calculate
how many I have at any time. Right?
And another way to write this is to write,
not in terms of the total
number of molecules in the body,
but in terms of the concentration
and to get concentration,
I just divide both sides by the volume,
right?
So concentration in the body as a function
of time is equal to this expression.
And I applauded that a for you last
time in that plots shown here where if I
looked on a simple plot of
concentration versus time,
concentration starts at a maximum and
it drops and it drops exponentially over
time. Now, and this, this turns out,
this very simple model matches very well
the way many drugs behave if you inject
them into the body,
if you inject them intravenously in
this case and that the concentration
immediately after the injection will be
the highest and concentration will drop
over time.
And for many drugs,
the way that they're eliminated from
the body does result in first order
elimination like this. So
you see this pattern. Now,
another useful parameter to describe here
is that is what's called the half life.
How long do drugs remain in the body?
What's the time course of that?
And the half life is defined as the time
that it takes for drug concentration to
drop from one value to half of that value.
So it might drop from c equals
c zero down to half of CS.
Jiro,
it might drop from half of [inaudible]
down to a quarter of c zero from a
quarter to an eighth.
What?
It doesn't matter where you start at
four processes where you have first order
elimination,
the time to get rid of half of the drugs
that are remaining is always the same.
That's a characteristic of
first order processes, right?
And that half life is just equal to
the natural log of two over the rate
constant.
So what this plot over here shows you
is how rapidly would drugs disappear for
drugs that had different half lives or
different rates of elimination and it's
plotted on a,
on a semi elog plot.
So this is the natural law or this
is the log based 10 actually of,
of um,
of,
of drug concentration in the
body as a function of time.
Here's a drug that has a half
life of 600 minutes long.
Half life means it stays in the
body for a long time. You clear it,
you get rid of it very slowly, a shorter
half life. You get rid of more quickly,
a very short half life,
you get rid of it very quickly.
So what's the result of that?
That for drugs with a short half life
drugs that the body gets rid of more
rapidly.
If the desired effect isn't
achieved with one dose,
I have to give another dose, right?
I'd have to give another dose.
If the drug had a half
life of six minutes,
I'd have to give another dose when the
drug concentration dropped down to a very
low level if I want to
maintain a high concentration.
Right? So knowing the half
life is really important.
And when you will see in a minute here,
um,
how this same factor
is important for drugs,
not just that her intravenously injected,
but for drugs that are
taken by pills as well.
But this is something that if you're,
if you're making a drug or
you're making it to sell,
you need to know about because you need
to tell people how frequently they can
take the drug. Right? And that depends
on how quickly your body gets rid of it.
That'll be more clear in
just a moment. I hope so.
That's the simplest possible model and
it matches very well the behavior of many
drugs when they're injected intravenously.
But how could I extend this to talk about,
to think about other situations as well.
Well,
what's dip rent if I don't directly
inject the molecules into the body,
but I take them by a pill.
That means if this is,
if this is most of your body.
Now when I take a pill,
I'm not introducing the drugs all at once,
but I'm putting them into my intestinal
system and they're being slowly absorbed
into the body,
right?
So one way to describe that is to
add another compartment to the model,
to add another compartment to this
simple model and say, here is a dose,
but it's a dose in form of a pill and
the patient is gonna swallow it. Nate,
would you mind closing that door for me?
And the patient is gonna swallow it.
And then that drug will be available
in a particular sub compartment of the
body.
Now it's going to be in the
intestine and it will be absorbed.
Thanks very much.
It will be absorbed from the
intestine into the bulk of the body,
into the circulatory system
where it can distribute. Now,
I'm not going to write down
the equations for this, but,
but you could do that and you could solve
this equation and what you would find
is,
is this curve here,
which matches your intuition.
Probably that what happens if I swallow
a pill and that pill dissolves in my
intestinal tract and then molecules
get absorbed slowly into the body.
Is that right after I take the pill,
the concentration hasn't changed inside
my blood yet inside the bulk of my body
because the molecules are
still outside your body.
They're still in your intestinal tract,
but they slowly get absorbed
and as they get absorbed,
concentration rises can see concentration
rising here and now what happens to
those molecules that are
circulating in your body? Well,
the same thing happens to them is what?
What happened to them if
they were injected is that
your body is trying to get
rid of them, right?
But at this point here,
the rate at which they're being absorbed
as much faster than the rate that your
body is getting rid of them.
And so the concentration is rising,
it eventually reaches a peak.
Most of the drug has now been absorbed
and concentrations start to fall.
What's happening during this phase
is that most of the drug has now been
absorbed.
So the rate at which you're getting,
it's coming into your body from the
pill that's dissolving and the molecules
being absorbed through the
intestinal track is being, uh,
that rate is less than the rate at
which your body is getting rid of it.
And so the concentration starts to drop.
So if you took Acetaminophen or you took,
if you took Ibuprofen,
which is Advil or Motrin,
what's happening in your body
is over some period of time,
usually 10 minutes to half an hour,
the molecules are being
absorbed from your intestine.
The concentration in your
blood is starting to rise.
If you took a pill and then you
measured concentrations in your blood,
you'd see those concentrations
start to rise. They reach a peak,
say half an hour after you take it and,
and hopefully whatever aches or pains
or whatever the reason you're taking the
medication for, you start to feel an
effect of it after some period of time.
And then concentration start to fall.
Now eventually they'll fall to such a
low level that the drug doesn't have its
desired effect anymore.
Right.
And in the event that your pain
hasn't gone away, you'll take another
dose, in which case the
same events we'll repeat,
right? Drug will be absorbed,
concentration will go up,
and then it'll start to fall again.
Right.
And so what you would see
on repeated doses here,
I show the effect of giving
one dose at time zero,
giving another dose at 120 minutes,
giving a third dose at 240 minutes.
So this would be taking a drug,
taking pills every two hours,
right?
And each one of the pills you take
yields the same behavior and the total
concentration in your blood is
just the sum of each of those,
the effect of each of those doses,
right?
So each of those doses would have
produced what are the dotted lines here?
The total effect that you
would see is this purple line,
right?
So let's say this drug is effective
when the concentration is 0.1
let's say this drug is effective.
When the concentration is 0.1 well
that means after what time is after 20
minutes or so after the first dose,
I get a level that's above 0.1 and I start
to feel some relief from the symptoms.
Concentrations peak, I'm feeling
good. They start to drop.
I know because I read the bottle, it
said take a dose every two hours, right?
I take another dose at two hours the
concentration rises again and so by,
by repeating these doses every two hours,
I maintain the concentration over 0.1
and I have an effect from the drug that
lasts long time.
What if at 0.3 what if had a concentration
of 0.3 you begin to see side effects,
right? What if had a concentration of
0.3 you begin to see side effects? Well,
no problem after the first dose.
After the second dose,
I've slipped into the range where I
might start to see side effects after the
third dose.
I'm clearly up into the range
where side effects might happen.
And so you're,
there's some danger as you repeat doses
that because drug is accumulating that
uh, you could slip into a range
where you start to see side effects.
Now the reason why you
can, uh, you can, um,
as I mentioned this last time,
but it should be more clear now
when you look at this picture,
the reason why you can take some drugs
like Ibuprofen or aspirin or drugs that
you typically buy over the counter without
a doctor's prescription and therefore
without a doctor's
guidance on taking them.
The reason why you can buy those and
use them yourself is because the toxic
levels don't occur until
hi on this chart,
right? Side effects don't occur
until high on this chart, right?
And so you can safely take it and without
much risk that side effects are going
to occur for many drugs.
However,
the side effects occur
at lower concentrations,
concentrations that are closer to the
dose you need in order to have a useful
response. And so those are ones that
you have to be more careful with.
Those are ones that physicians don't want
to prescribe unless they're seeing you
frequently enough that they can monitor
how well you're doing with the drug.
Right. And, um, does she give you
some idea about why that happens?
Right.
So people have been
thinking for a long time.
We talked about why different
modes of administration,
oral administration is the preferred mode
for almost all kinds of drugs because
it can be self administered.
It's very convenient and people
don't mind taking drugs that way. Uh,
but there are problems with it.
For example,
this problem of how do you maintain
constant levels within this safe range,
uh, over long periods of time. And um,
so this just shows that same plot again
with the levels rising and falling with
the minimum effective and the maximum
tolerated concentrations shown explicitly
here.
And what's shown by the Blue Line
is sort of what you might prefer,
some kind of a drug delivery system that
gives you long lasting concentrations,
but concentrations that don't rise and
fall in the way that they do when you're
taking a, when you're taking
individual doses repeatedly.
All right.
Now could you do this with an oral,
with a pill?
Could you achieve this sort
of long lasting constant
concentration with a pill?
Will you could in some rare circumstances,
right?
Think about how would that happen? Well,
maybe a drug has a very long half life.
If you could design a drug that
had a very, very long half life,
you could main Kate tank
concentrations for a long time. Nate,
you have a question? Yes, so let me,
let me get to that in just a minute.
Did, but that's a really good,
that's a really good point. So, but
an alternate to that would be to say,
what if I had a drug that
that had a long half life,
well that would naturally
have this kind of a pattern.
Okay.
Instead of that,
what if I design a pill
that releases it slowly?
So thinking about a couple of slides ago,
what if I designed a pill that was
absorbed very slowly from the intestine,
right?
If I make it absorbed so slowly,
that drug is continually coming into
your body over a long period of time,
right? The peak in this diagram
occurs after only 30 minutes or so.
What if I designed a a pill such that
the drug was absorbed over five hours?
Right?
Then I could extend,
then I could extend this period here and
I could have drug concentrations that
remain long,
a long time.
This would be five hours instead of 60
minutes down here where the peak occurs,
right?
What's the limit of that?
Why is there a limit on how far
you can go with that approach?
Jasmine? There's only so much drug, so,
so it might be that you
know as if you do that,
then your pills getting larger and larger
and presumably, and there's only so,
so big a pill you could swallow
so that that could be a problem.
But most compounds fairly potent.
If he had something that was potent,
you could still put several days' worth
into a pill that was of a reasonable
size. So that might not be
the limitation for every drug.
But that's a really good point.
What's another limitation?
That's another limitation. Yeah. Neilia
so that's a real, that's a real
safety is a really good point.
And what I've been talking about here
is how these things behave in an average
person.
And what if you happen to absorb drugs
much more quickly than the average person
and you've got several days' worth
of drug you're taking in one pill,
but it gets absorbed more quickly.
You could go into this
toxic or side effect range.
So safety is certainly an issue.
Yeah.
One more.
How often do you eat?
Why? Why? Why don't we
only eat once a day?
Yeah.
Sorry.
Because that's the rate at which
you absorb food. Right? And that's,
that's the rate at which
your intestinal system works.
Things pass through at a certain rate,
right? You can't really slow that down,
right?
You can't really,
you can eat more and feel full for a
period of time feel satisfied. But that,
but you can't,
you won't continue to be
absorbing more drugs because,
because whatever you take into your
intestine passes through in a matter of
hours,
right?
There's a transit rate through your
intestinal system that is not very
changeable.
And so a pill that you take can,
is only going to be there as long as
it's still in your intestinal tract.
And there's a limit to how
long it will last, right?
It's not going to last forever.
We know this from our experience with
food and eliminating the waste products of
food, right? That there's a time course
there that can't be altered very much.
And so there's a limit to how much
you can do in terms of sustaining or
prolonging release with an oral system.
So people have designed other methods
and as, as I mentioned, this is,
this is my research lab.
This is my specialty. So I'm
going to talk about some,
um, some things that we've designed
to try to get around these, uh,
these barriers in,
um,
for certain kinds of drugs
in certain situations.
One way that you could get around it is
by designing not something that's taken
orally, but by designing a
delivery system that's implanted.
All right. Now when you start thinking
about this is not a pill but an implant,
you're automatically limiting it to
certain kinds of conditions, right?
You wouldn't want to get an
implant for a headache, right?
Or something that you
know is going to go away.
You're talking about serious
medical problems that are ongoing.
So this might be for something like
treating diabetes where you need to take
drugs every day,
multiple times a day.
It might be pretreating something like
cancer where a course of chemotherapy
could last for several weeks
or several months, right?
It might be for treating
longterm disorders like, uh,
like hemophilia where you're
deficient in factor eight,
a protein in the blood and you need
to have a injections of factor eight
continuously, right? So it's only for
certain kinds of things, but, but,
but um,
but you could imagine that there are
those kinds of medical problems that you
could treat. Well, here's
one way to achieve long,
long release of drug into the body
from an implant to make implants out of
biocompatible materials like polymers.
So what's shown on the bottom of this
slide here is an implant that's made of a
gray substance, which is a
polymer, a biocompatible polymer.
Imagine it's something like, um, like uh,
the contact lenses that you would
put in contact with your eye.
These are materials that are synthetic
materials, but uh, their, uh,
their Ma that your body doesn't respond
to them as foreign objects very strongly,
right?
You can put,
you can put some polymers in contact
with one of the most sensitive areas of
your body,
your eye,
and it can remain there for a long period
of time without very much response of
your body to the material.
Well,
what if you took that material
embedded within it drug molecules.
And that's what's shown here. And in
fact, it's not just molecules of drug,
it's solid particles of drug,
which has shown is the orange dots here.
So that this whole thing is maybe the
size of a coin, maybe the size of a dime.
Right? And what I'm showing you here
is a cross section of that dime, dime,
laying flat. I cut it like this.
You're looking at it from this side.
So it's a millimeter or so in depth,
several millimeters in diameter,
and it's a solid polymer.
But inside of it are particles of
the drug that you want to deliver.
And what these graphs show
our experiments that we did.
This was back in the late 1980s where we
put drug molecules into these polymers
and then just drop them into a test
tube and ask the question, could we,
could we release drugs slowly from
these implants so we could make a long
lasting pill,
essentially make a long lasting
implant that slowly released drugs.
And this shows for a drug that is
used to treat Parkinson's disease,
another sort of chronic indication where
patients have to take drugs every day
for the rest of their life.
Uh,
and this shows that when you drop these
implants into a test tube full of water,
the dopamine is released and it's
released for a fairly long period of time.
This is days here. So this point
here is 30 days, about a month.
So one of these systems released
a drug for a period of a month,
one released for almost three months here,
a sort of continuous and
reliable sorts of drugs.
So you can make implants that release
drug molecules over long periods of time.
And the rest of these curves just show
you that you could do this with, with uh,
drugs like dopamine that are small and
molecular weight and water soluble.
You could do it with proteins which
are higher in molecular weight and uh,
and uh,
also water soluble.
You could even do it with gene therapy
vectors with plasmids we talked about
several weeks ago. Plasma
DNA, these are big molecules,
very difficult to administer,
right?
We talked about how hard it is to
get plasma DNA inside of cells,
but you can put them into these polymers
and they'll slowly be released from the
polymer over a long period of time.
So one could potentially make a long
lasting gene therapy delivery system.
One of the advantages of making these
materials out of polymers is that we now
know how to, you can make all
kinds of things out of polymers.
That's one of the nice features of
plastics or polymers is that you can mold
them and shape them into all
sorts of kinds of devices.
So here this is that
same kind of material,
but instead of making a,
a coin out of it,
we coated it onto the surface of a wire.
So this is a bare wire and it's
the kind of wire that, uh, that um,
you can put into the brain and you can
measure recordings of what's happening in
the, in the brain, extra cellular space.
So you can measure action potentials
and electrical activity in the brain by
putting electrodes in. And physicians
do this all the time to measure,
to measure activity in the brain, in
patients that have epilepsy, for example.
But one of the problems
with these materials is that
when you put them into the
brain,
they're not completely biocompatible.
The brain does respond to them and
it will form a scar around them and
eventually the electrode
won't work anymore.
So we coated these electrodes with
a polymer that contained drug.
In this case it's a drug dexamethazone.
It's a steroid that prevents
scar formation locally.
And so you make a wire that's able to
record but it's also able to deliver a
drug. And so now when this
is placed in the brain,
you're not only can make the recordings
but the drug is slowly being released
and it prevents scar formation around
the outside of the electrode and the
electrode will function for a longer
period of time inside the, uh,
the patient. So this is an example
of taking a medical device,
the kind of devices
we've been talking about,
and we'll continue to talk
about and making it safer
and better by adding a drug
delivery.
The other advantage to this is that I
didn't have to deliver steroids all over
the body in order to
accomplish this effect, right?
We've put the steroids right on the
device and they act locally when they're
needed. So you don't have steroids
delivered all over the body,
but only at the site where you're
doing the intervention. Well,
this has become a very big business
in, um, in, uh, uh, around the world.
And that's because several companies
took this kind of technology that, uh,
that had been developed and used it in
a very clinically important application.
What this shows you here is a stent.
It's made of a metal.
This is one kind of it.
There are many sorts of versions
of this and I imagine this is a,
this is a stent that's expanded,
uh, over this tube that's inside.
But you can imagine this design here,
which looks like a kind of a chicken
wire fence could be collapsed,
right?
Because the wires are,
would bend and you can collapse
this into a smaller form.
So what they do is they collapse this
into a form around the end of a tube
called a catheter.
And so this a shrunken version of this
stent shrunk and only in its diameter
being reduced is then put into your
body at the catheter is a long narrow
plastic tube that can be inserted into
a a distal artery like your femoral
artery in your leg.
And then physicians know how to move
this catheter up into your body and
actually into the blood
blood vessels of your heart.
So they put this tube up
into your coronary artery.
Now one of the manifestations of heart
disease is that coronary arteries become
a sclerotic there.
They become narrowed because you
get atherosclerotic plaques there.
If the vessel becomes narrowed than
blood can't flow through very easily and
that can lead to pain in your chest
because your heart is not getting enough
blood and can lead to a heart attack
or loss of blood flow to the heart and
death of that tissue.
So when that process starts to happen,
what if you put one of these catheters
in and I didn't tell you that the
catheter also has a balloon on the tip
and the balloon is underneath this stent.
So once you've got it in place,
you blow up the balloon,
the stent becomes larger,
it forces the blood vessel to become
open and then you deflate the balloon.
And because this is made of metal, it
doesn't deflate when the balloon deflates,
but it stays there inside your blood
vessel holding the blood vessel open.
So now blood flow can continue.
All right.
And this is a very common medical therapy.
This done as an alternative
to heart bypass.
We'll talk about heart bypass
operations, uh, in a few weeks.
But instead of having a new
blood vessel put into your heart,
which is a major operation, you can
put this stent in, blow up the balloon,
inflate the vet vessel,
and the stent is left behind in
order to keep the vessel open.
Well, you could imagine that this
is not a normal circumstance.
Your blood vessels were not designed to
have a piece of metal inserted in them
to hold them open.
And in fact,
they respond to this and they respond
in the way that your body responds to
having foreign objects put into it.
It tries to form a scar around it.
And often that scar formation will
occur so aggressively that scarf tissue
starts to fill in the vessel
where that you've opened.
And this process is called restenosis.
So what these companies did was took
these stents which were known to be very
effective and physicians are very
capable and able to to put these into the
body, into the coronary
vascular system now readily.
And they coded the wires with a polymer.
And that's what's shown
in this cartoon here.
The yellow is a wire and
this gray is a polymer,
like the polymers I've been describing
and why coated with a polymer,
because now you can put drugs inside
the polymer and the drugs will be slowly
released from this polymer coating.
So this becomes not just a stent,
but what they call him, the
industry, a drug eluting stent.
It releases drugs that prevent
scar formation locally.
So a patient that has heart disease
gets one of these stents put in their
vascular system,
they opened up the artery and now that
stent not only holds the artery open,
but it contains enough drug molecules
that are released slowly over time that
prevents this restenosis.
And the vessel stays open for hopefully
the rest of their life. Right.
We're going to talk more about about uh,
stents and mechanical objects
like this that are used for uh,
for medical therapy later.
The important part here is the,
is the coding on the skin which releases
drugs very slowly and it's really just
an extension of what I showed
you in the last couple of slides.
These were really at least
into the approved by the
FDA and in 2002 or so a few
years ago and became one of the biggest
selling drug products ever in a US
history.
Uh,
which tells you something about sort of
the clinical need for things like this.
Again,
like that other system,
one of the advantages is you're not
delivering drugs over the whole body but
only in the vessel where you need it,
right?
Only in the vessel where
the scar is going to form.
And so you can deliver drugs locally,
you can prevent side effects that
would happen in other places.
One more example.
And in that,
in that example I just
showed you that you, you,
you have a stent which is going to remain
in the patient for a long period of
time. And there's a good reason
to put the stent there, right?
To hold this vessel open so that
you can get good blood flow.
In other situations,
you might want to introduce an implant,
but you don't want the implant to
last forever, right? Because it's not,
it's not a natural material.
You might like the implant to go away.
And so there are some polymers like this
that can be made into devices like this
implant here,
which is again about the size of a coin,
but it's made of a very special polymer
that's different than the kinds that are
used in contact lenses in
that it slowly dissolves.
So if I implant this co coin made of
this kind of material into the body,
it will slowly dissolve.
So if I implanted under the skin and
then I go back and I look several months
later, the implant itself is
totally, totally disappeared.
Um, and you, of course you
can't do this without any,
with just any kind of material,
has to be a very special material is
both biocompatible that your body doesn't
respond to and that dissolves down
to molecules that are not toxic,
right? So it's not so easy
to design these things,
but there are some materials
that are available.
Now what we did in this experiment,
which showed that you could load these
polymers with chemotherapy drugs and
these are just three
different chemotherapy drugs
and you could load them in
such a way that if you put
this material into water, uh,
the chemotherapy drugs would be slowly
released. And that's what's shown here.
This is with the, uh,
the drug, uh, Bcnu. It's,
it's a drug that's commonly used to treat,
or at least it was in the 1990s,
commonly used to treat brain cancer and
it's released over a period of seven
days.
90% of the is released.
And then the last 10% comes out
over a period of several months.
If we look longer than that,
all the drug is gone now.
And then the polymer itself starts to
dissolve. And so by three months later,
four months later,
the whole device has disappeared,
but it disappears in an orderly fashion.
In fact,
we engineered it to work just this way,
such that most of the drug would be
released rapidly over a period of a week.
10% of the drug would be released more
slowly over a period of several months.
And then the device itself
would be completely gone in
a period of six months or
so. So what would you use this for? Well,
this was designed as a,
um,
as a device that you would give to
neurosurgeons so that they could improve
therapy of brain tumors.
And you probably know that,
uh, that, that tumors of the brain
are among the most difficult to treat.
If you get a tumor in the
central nervous system,
they have very poor
prognosis or life expectancy.
People that get aggressive brain tumors
die within a very short time after it's
diagnosed, unfortunately. And that can,
that situation hasn't changed much
over the last hundred years. Um,
and one of the reasons is
what we mentioned earlier,
that the brain is protected from chemical
entry by the blood brain barrier.
Capillaries in your brain don't
allow molecules to move across them.
And there's good reasons for that so
that your brain chemistry can remain
constant throughout the day.
But because of that blood brain barrier,
if you give drugs the normal way
by taking pills or injections,
you get high doses everywhere else,
but not very much gets into the brain.
We thought that when they do
neurosurgery to remove a tumor,
which is commonly done,
the brain is exposed,
then the surgeon has an opportunity
then to do something extraordinary.
And that is to after the surgery,
they removed the tumor,
then they could place these wafers
inside the surgical resection cavity.
So where the tumor used to be,
you place these coins that are made of
this degradable polymer that released
these drugs very slowly and the patient
leaves the operating room with most of
their tumor gone.
And in addition,
these drug delivery systems,
which are releasing drugs slowly to
kill any tumor cells that remain in the
vicinity of the surgical site.
Uh,
this is, uh, this is a different
strategy for drug delivery, right?
It's a very specialized
strategy for delivering drugs.
It's one that takes advantage of the fact
that you're having a medical procedure
already.
Can we design something that's going to
make that procedure even more effective?
And this was approved by the FDA.
It's now the standard of care for
treating brain tumors at most countries in
the, uh, in the world.
Okay.
How could you make this more,
how could you make this kind of technology
or this kind of engineering more
accessible? Right? Here was an example,
actually several examples of very
specialized applications of this different
form of drug delivery.
Yeah.
Well,
one way you could do it is by,
is by shrinking these devices down so
that they're so small that could be
introduced through a needle.
Right?
Those wafers I showed you before,
it could be used by surgeons because they,
the tissue is exposed, right?
And you can implant things in.
That's not the case for
many other indications.
Surgery isn't done in
every medical situation.
But if you could put a needle into the
body and introduce these delivery systems
through needles,
then maybe that would make it
better for other forms of, uh,
of disease.
So these are microparticles.
They're made of the same
kinds of degradable polymers,
but they're very tiny particles now
and in, in section this afternoon,
we'll talk about how you make these
kinds of particles and, and, and uh,
you'll actually be able to make
some, uh, but, uh, these are,
these particular ones are made of the
same kind of polymer that slowly degrades,
but they're very small. They're a micron
or so in diameter. So they're much,
much smaller than a needle and they
can be injected through a needle.
You just imagine
suspending these particles,
which looked like dust in water and
then injecting them through a needle.
They also have the property that you
can put drugs in them at fairly high
concentration and the drugs
are released slowly over time.
So that if I put a needle into a
tissue and introduce these particles,
the particles will sit there at the
tissue side and they'll release the drug
molecules for a long period of
time just like the implants do.
And so just to show
that this works and how,
how tiny you might be able to make the
particles and how locally you might be
able to deliver them.
We made some particles like this and
we injected them into the eye of a,
of an animal that had a retinal disease.
The the animal had a disease of the retina
as such, that would cause blindness.
And ordinarily there are many drugs
that are known to prevent this kind of
blindness, but they have
short half lives, right?
So if I inject the drug directly into
the eye, it disappears within a day.
Okay.
And so here's a drug that works.
Here's a condition that
it works in it's edition,
that it's a condition that causes a
very serious medical problem blindness.
But in order to use the drug, you have
to get an injection in the eye every day.
That's the only way to get concentrations
high enough for it to be effective.
But if you put it into the
particles that I showed you before,
you put the same drug into the particles,
you inject the particles into the eye,
the particles stay there in the eye,
they stay there for a long time and
drug concentration now lasts for 30 days
instead of one day.
So this takes what would
be an unthinkable therapy,
right? Difficult to think. Even if
blind, if you want to avoid blind,
it's difficult to think about getting
an injection in your eye once a day for
the rest of
the time you want to remain eyesight.
But you might think about it once a month,
right?
If it meant the difference between being
able to see and not being able to see
if we can make the particles better
such that they worked for three months,
that makes it even more possible.
If they work for a year,
then once a year and you can see that's
a therapy that would be acceptable to
most people. So it's, it's an
example of an approach but it,
but it also shows the constraints
of the approach, right?
So far we can do a month,
we'd like to be able to do longer and
as we do longer, this will become, uh,
a more,
uh,
therapy that's more likely to be
adopted into clinical practice.
And you can imagine that making it longer
requires better engineering of these
particles and it's hard to make particles
that are really small but hold on to
drugs for a long time.
Right?
That's a hard thing to make particles
that are really small but hold on to drugs
for a long time.
What we've gotten good at so far is
making particles that are really,
really small. So these are the, these
are sort of the state of the art.
These are particles that are
made about degradable polymer.
They're only 150 nanometers in size.
So now much smaller than a micron,
even these are the size of a virus.
So we were talking about smallpox virus
before a naturally occurring pathogen.
These are synthetic polymers made totally
in the laboratory that are the same
size as a virus and they're made of a
polymer that's well known to be safe.
And they also contain drug.
These particular particles, uh,
were made by a graduate student who
worked with me named Amaryllis Sanchez,
and Amaryllis was able to put 20% by
weight of a chemotherapy drug inside these
very tiny particles,
particles the size of a virus.
And even though the
particles are very tiny,
the drug comes out relatively slowly
over a period of about a week. Now, why,
why make, why make a
particle so small? Well,
it turns out that these particles are
so small that they can actually enter
cells like viruses.
They can infect cells only they don't
infect in the same way that a virus does
because they're totally synthetic,
right? They don't reproduce.
They just sit inside the cells and they
release chemotherapy drugs in this case.
Well,
that's makes possible a totally
different strategy for treating cancer.
You know,
and one of the problems with treating
cancer is that cancer drugs have to get
deep inside the cell in order to work.
Most of them work by inhibiting cell
division and most of the targets for
inhibiting cell division or not just
within cells, they're within the nucleus,
inside the cell.
And the approach for chemotherapy is to
deliver these toxic drugs all over the
body and hope that they get into tumor
cells and hope that they get into tumor
cells at high enough concentrations
that they can reach these targets,
deepen the nucleus.
Well,
what is possible we think with this
approach is that you can design not just,
um,
long release of drugs.
I didn't do a very good job
there. Uh, but you can. Um,
but you can design particles that will
specifically recognize tumor cells in the
same way that viruses recognize tumor
cells or specific cells that will enter
only certain cells and that they'll
release their drugs only when they've
entered the correct cell.
And that would be
potentially a much safer,
more effective a form of chemotherapy.
Okay.
So I've taken in this lecture
and covered a lot of material.
Uh, but, uh,
the important things I hope are too,
which I've emphasized I hope are
to think about ordinary forms,
are common forms of drug administration
like pills and injections.
And understand a little bit about how
those forms of administration lead two
concentration changes within the body as
a function of time and how those forms
are limited in some ways.
Now, even with those,
with those limitations,
obviously medical therapy has advanced
tremendously because of the availability
of drugs,
right?
Antibiotics have changed our lifespan,
People don't die of infectious diseases
because of vaccines and because there
are antibiotics that you can
take sometimes orally. We
all have taken them, right?
You've taken antibiotics
and you got better. Uh,
so drug therapy has been
an incredible advance.
The second part I want you to think
about is how sort of engineering of
materials in the case I've described here,
uh,
could allow you to think about making
systems for drug delivery that are even
better,
that can take existing drugs and expose
them to the body in different ways such
that they're safer. And more effective
at treating certain kinds of diseases.
Okay. So we'll, we'll meet at a
section this afternoon, right?
Any questions?
Great.
See you this afternoon.